Guten Morgen Linus. Du, ich habe hier so ein Staatstrojaner, was ist denn das?
Da bin ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt über Frag. Ich habe das Wort in meinem Leben noch nicht gehört, aber also ich würd's mir auf mein Handy installieren.
Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertzweiundachtzig vom vierundzwanzigsten Februar zwanzig einundzwanzig. Euer Gedanken und Spaß Trojaner, der sich in,
euer Hirn einfräst und dann aktiviert wird, wenn's wichtig ist.
Ja, so ist es. Und für für die Chronistinnen und äh wir sind jetzt am, also wir haben jetzt gerade, wir sind jetzt gerade in der Phase, wo wir die Impfung liegenlassen,
Die zweite Welle vorzeitig für beendet erklärt haben, damit wir die Dritte nicht verpassen, in die es jetzt, in die wir gerade reinrutschen, ist super, läuft.
Wäre doch, du wär doch schade, wenn wir die jetzt verpassen würden.
Sorry. Es tut, wir kennen das aus den Zoom Calls, ne? Sorry, hallo ey, es tut mir voll leid, voll geile zweite Welle, aber ich habe jetzt einfach schon die Anschlusswelle.
Season drei fängt gleich an. Ich muss schnell einschalten. Ja, wo ist es? Aber was soll man machen.
Das Land ist eine Katastrophe, ja. Gut, dass ich so viel zu tun habe, dann lese ich den ganzen Mist schon gar nicht mehr.
Ciao. So ist es.
Also vor allem ist dann das Geile ist ja, dass also für mich ist jetzt echt immer noch so ein Mystery. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall Leute, die die das für eine,
Die ernsthaft meinen, dass sie dass sie irgendwie froh sein können, dass sie irgendwie was Gutes getan haben, wenn ihnen eine Impfung mit Astra angeboten wird und sie die verweigern.
Das ist so ähm und es gibt aber offenbar auch irgendwie halt äh eine ganze Menge, die von den Impfstoffen liegen bleibt, weil Deutschland die scheiß Impfstoff Impflogistik nicht hinkriegt,
es ist zum Heulen. Das ist es ist nur noch zum Heulen dieses dieses ähm dieses Land, ja.
Würde am liebsten auswandern in Land, was es im Griff hat, aber.
Die haben dann andere Mängel. Das ist natürlich das äh große Problem. Das ist es gibt nichts, was richtig nur durchgehend geil ist. Da muss man leider Abstriche machen, aber ist natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht.
Wieso Neuseeland? Welchen Abstrich haben die denn in Neuseeland gemacht? Ja gut, sind am anderen Ende der Welt. Der ist aber auch der einzige Abstrich, den die machen mussten.
Five Eis und so, also na ja, da würde einem schon was einfall.
Die haben wir bei uns auch.
Das stimmt. Hm.
Okay, kommen wir zum Feedback. Also, Feedback.
In der Sendung zu den Gainstop Aktienscherzen haben wir uns ja relativ ausführlich über das von Tims Wohnwagen unterhalten. Das fanden einige von euch witzig, deswegen weist uns Martin jetzt darauf hin, dass bei ihnen,
Tatsächlich Wohnwagen geschortet werden und er schickt uns einen Link auf den Paderborner Wohnmobilprozess.
Das ist etwas, was Paderborn beschäftigt,
und ähm Betrüger hatten das Wohngebiet einer Familie aus Bielefeld gemietet und dann weiterverkauft,
Und die äh so äh also genau das, was ich ja auch mit Tipps Wohnwagen gemacht habe.
Und äh der Prozess ging aber weiter, weil daraufhin haben die Opfer im Internet ein erfundenes Wohnmobil angeboten, dann sind die Betrüger wiedergekommen und dann haben sie die der Polizei gemeldet und jetzt ist das alles äh also es ist spannend, wenn
Paderborn und Bielefeld, da ist richtig was los. Und ähm ja, Martin äh kommentiert noch seltsamerweise heißt das dann Betrug und nicht Investition,
Schöne Grüße und macht weiter so. Ja, Martin, vielen Dank.
Der Paderborner, wo wir Prozess ist, für uns natürlich jetzt durchaus von Interesse.
Mal gucken, wer da am Ende welche Preise noch in die Höhe treiben wird,
Dann hatten wir in unserer äh Feedback-Runde im Klapphaus äh noch einige Diskussionen über den ich glaube, ich nicht äh besonders.
Gut in der Sendung besprochen habe. Deswegen möchte ich das jetzt nochmal ein bisschen ähm konkretisieren.
Zwar habe ich da ja so ein bisschen gesagt, okay, das ist ein Hackbag, ja und da wurde von einigen gefragt, na ja, aber ein Hackback ist doch eigentlich wenn die Infrastruktur der Angreifer gehackt wird, um einen Schaden abzuwenden und ob die überhaupt gehackt haben,
gar nicht so unbedingt in dieser Meldung vor. Das ist korrekt. Ähm ich fand,
Es ist eher das, womit Hackbacks verteidigt werden oder womit Hackbacks beworben werden. Nämlich, dass es einen laufenden, ein laufendes Angriffsgeschehen gibt.
Welches durch Angriffe oder Eingriffe in die Integrität von Systemen.
Gemindert werden kann. Ja und was hier passiert ist, ist ja, dass sie die Command and Control Infrastruktur übernommen haben.
Ob das jetzt ein Hack war oder nicht, sei oder hingestellt, aber dass sie ja jetzt dann die Systeme, die mit dieser Kommandanten-Control-Infrastruktur,
ähm kommunizieren,
quasi desinfizieren. Und das ist ein Eingriff in die Integrität der Systeme der Betroffenen, ne? Es es sind zwar gehackte Systeme, aber jetzt wirkt,
staatliche Stelle auf diese Systeme ein. Und das kann eben,
sicherlich in dieser Form nicht legal gewesen sein, sodass dafür haben die nicht die Befugnis, da gibt es dann eben auch
inzwischen noch von weiseren Leuten die die Juristerei noch genauer studiert haben eben auch gleichlautende Kommentare die eben sagen nee das äh durften die mit Sicherheit
nicht. So, spannend ist, dass.
Ja wie ich schon sagte, unterm Strich eben etwas,
positives ist, was da geschehen ist. Das ändert aber nichts daran, dass dass konkret aber eben nicht legal war. Mich erinnert das so ein bisschen, ich will das jetzt mal äh etwas übertreiben, aber es gab vor.
Dass es viele Jahre her, da gab's, glaube ich, in Nordrhein-Westfalen so ein Folterprozess. Da hat ein Polizist,
einem des Mordes an einem Kind verdächtigten Folter angedroht. Und der hat dann.
Tatsächlich unter der Androhung der Folter das Versteck verraten, indem der dieses entführte Kind irgendwie gefangen gehalten hat.
Ähm wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, wurde da dann leider eine Leiche gefunden, was das Ganze natürlich jetzt.
Nur noch dramatischer gemacht hat. Trotzdem musste sich dann natürlich dieser Polizist dafür verantworten, was er da getan hat,
Und das war auch etwas, wo der Polizist auch, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, wie gesagt, das ist viele Jahre her, ist etwas gewesen, wo der Polizist hat, gesagt hat, so, ja klar, mir war bewusst, dass ich hier einen,
begehe und dass ich mich dafür verantworten muss, aber es war von meiner Seite kalkuliert. Nichtsdestotrotz muss der natürlich, äh so war zumindest damals die Debatte,
hart bestraft werden, weil du eben nicht sagen kannst, naja, die Gesetze gelten nur, wenn es schief geht und nicht, wenn es nicht schief geht, weil wenn du wenn du so argumentierst, dann hast du halt auch rucki zucki da dein,
Guantanamo stehen, ne? Und das ist die Sache mit mit dieser Geschichte. Rechtlich ist das sehr schwierig, wie ich auch,
ähm versucht habe in der Sendung zu sagen, weil wenn man diese Befugnis definieren möchte, wenn man dem Staat diese Befugnis geben möchte, du darfst Schadsoftware von den von den Rechnern deiner Bürgerinnen entfernen.
Da musst du das halt auf eine Weise machen, die möglichst keinen Missbrauch in anderer Form ähm erlaubt.
Tatsächlich, jetzt wird's nur noch spannender.
Will das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei tatsächlich dafür die rechtliche Grundlage schaffen für das BSI,
Das analysiere ich grade, weil ich da als Sachverständiger geladen bin nächste Woche in den
ja wahrscheinlich eher Innenausschuss des Deutschen Bundestags, dazu kommen wir gleich nochmal. Also
Da werden wir noch lange und viel weiter drüber reden. Gleichzeitig ist es einer der seltenen Fälle, ne, also wir diskutieren ja gerade in diesen IT-Sicherheitsgesetzen, äh Fälle, die,
letztendlich relativ selten eintreten,
Also die Diskussion ist noch nicht vorbei. Tim, ich sehe, du hast schon den Daschner Prozess in die Show Notes getan. Kannst du jetzt vielleicht noch, weißt du, ob der Polizist dann am Ende äh verurteilt wurde oder nicht.
Äh es gab eine Verwarnung mit Geldstrafe von neunzig Tagessätzen zu je hundertzwanzig Euro insgesamt zehntausendachthundert gegen den Wolfgang Dashler, den,
Angeklagten und nochmal sechzig Tagessätze zu sechzig Euro, also dreitausendsechshundert Euro gegen die zweite,
Person, das ist der Kriminalhauptkommissar, der ja, da irgendwie auch noch mit beteiligt war.
Mhm.
Also es gab in dem Sinne eine Verurteilung ähm ja.
Das sind so das sind so Ferdinand von Dingern ne, wo der irgendwie so kannst dann immer fragen, ist der konkrete Fall jetzt äh wie wie beurteilst du den konkreten Fall und wie beurteilst du das allgemeine,
rechts gut. Äh zum Glück müssen wir solche Diskussionen nicht führen, unsere Welt ist äh etwas einfacher, meistens. Also wir diskutieren's nochmal, wenn ich nächste Woche in der Sendung das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei dann wahrscheinlich genauer behandeln möchte.
Aufmerksam machen möchte ich auf die Kampagne, auf die haben wir hier schon öfter aufmerksam gemacht, die jetzt aus dem Umfeld kommt, also eine europäische Internationale Kampagne,
die eine,
europäische Bürgerinnen Initiative anstrengt. Und zwar zum Verbot biometrischer Massenüberwachung. Wir haben über Reclamy Face hier schon öfter gesprochen, aber jetzt ist quasi die Phase, wo wirklich für diese,
ähm die ähm.
Äh gesammelt wird. Und ähm da könnt ihr euch jetzt alle mal schön eintragen. Das ist ein.
Longshot, da müssen innerhalb eines Jahres eine Million Unterschriften in mindestens sieben EU-Ländern gesammelt werden und dann hat man die, hat die, haben die Initiatorinnen die Möglichkeit, die äh EU-Kommission äh,
Vorschläge zu unterbreiten, da muss sich
Kommission in einer Anhörung dem EU-Parlament gegenüber äußern wie sie sich beabsichtigt dazu zu verhalten und das ist eine ganze Menge Unterschriften, die da gesammelt werden wollen und
es geht eben eigentlich darum, dass biometrische Massenüberwachung jetzt schon stattfindet. Wir haben die ersten Testballons,
Thema Südkreuz Thema wie heißt dieses diese andere die es da noch gab? Ne?
Das Problem von biometrischer Massenerfassung ist eben, dass es dass sie wie im Onlineleben,
ermöglichen soll, ne? Also ein Videodatenstrom ist relativ viel an Daten, aber wenn du den sinnvoll reduzierst, wer, wann, wo war.
Dann kannst du damit eben mittelfristig äh eine Überwachung des öffentlichen Raumes so einfach machen,
eine Überwachung des Internets. Und ähm das ist eine Risikotechnologie, für die man vielleicht erstmal das gesetzliche Rahmenwerk haben möchte, bevor sie entsteht.
Ja, wo es vor allem sehr sinnvoll wäre, wenn man sich so sozusagen erstmal ganz grundsätzlich entscheidet, dass es,
erstmal ohne besonderen Grund, der dann mit vielleicht Ausnahmen zugelassen wird, verboten ist und zwar jedem. Und das ähm wäre,
sehr wertvolle Grundlage, denn wenn das nicht so ist, dann werden wir sehen, dass das richtig Fahrt aufnimmt und dass das dann auch irgendwann fast nicht mehr wegzubekommen ist,
Ist genau der richtige Zeitpunkt, da nochmal das Ganze, dem Ganzen nochmal einen Riegel vorzuschieben.
Genau und deswegen, also wir haben es bei vielen anderen Themen zu spät gemacht, ne,
Wir haben dann irgendwie Datenschutzreformen in den Zweitausendern gemacht als Facebook schon Milliardenkonzern war.
Äh lasst uns hoffen, dass dass uns nicht bei äh biometrischer Massenüberwachung passiert. Deswegen wirklich bitte gerne dort unterzeichnen,
bitte gerne weitergeben. Es ist eben eine Petition, die äh die dann irgendwie äh,
also Wert vor dem Parlament hat. Und das bedeutet, man muss dann natürlich auch eben vernünftige Daten angeben, um die kontrollierbar zu machen. Trotzdem dauert's irgendwie keine fünf Minuten, sich dort einzutragen.
Schon mal probiert hat und an Datumsfeld gescheitert ist, das äh scheint jetzt zu funktionieren. Ich konnte mittlerweile meiner äh meine Teilnahme erfolgreich eintragen.
Ja, das ist natürlich von äh von von äh Open Source Fundamentalisten gebaut worden und wurde nicht unter Safari getestet und hat entsprechend auf dem auf dem MACOS Standard Browser in paar Stunden nicht funktioniert.
Man muss auch immer noch Schrägstriche eingeben, warum auch immer, aber ist zumindest steht es da, dass man das muss.
Okay,
Also kriegt man schon hin. Wie das immer so ist, wenn du so einen Massen äh Camp Paine startest, dann hast du halt in den ersten Stunden Probleme und dummerweise kostet dich das natürlich auch echt Unterzeichnerin, ne? Äh weil,
die Welle ist einmal auf Twitter und dann haben sie halt geklickt oder nicht. Und wenn das irgendwie nicht funktioniert hat, deswegen gerne,
andere Leute davon überzeugen und dort zu.
Eine zweite Welle auslösen, genau.
Ja, kann man noch eine zweite und eine dritte Welle gebrauchen.
So und du darfst wieder in den Bundestag mit Maske wahrscheinlich oder wie läuft das alles online jetzt? Äh erzähl auch mal.
Also mir wurde angeboten, äh eine Videoschaltung oder vor Ort, da ich ja nicht allzu weit weg vom äh Reichstag wohne,
liebäugele ich eigentlich mit dem Gedanken dorthin zu gehen, andererseits sind, glaube ich, fast alle anderen Sachverständigen auch Remoter, weshalb ich nicht weiß, wie viele Leute ich da antreffe. Ich habe die Entscheidung noch nicht so ganz getroffen, werde ich wahrscheinlich morgen,
übermorgen mir mal überlegen, wie ich das mache, ob ich lieber dorthin gehe und mich von denen dort filmen lasse oder das hier,
selber zu Hause mache und es wäre halt eigentlich auch mal witzig so, weißt du?
Eine Sachverständigenauskunft an den Bundestag in Unna Books zu Hause zu machen. Das ist eigentlich auch lustig, weißt du? Also der Reiz ist da, weißt du was? Kriegst du die Chance nochmal, ne?
Lino ist, aber was ist denn, wenn sie dann die Nationalhymne einspielen und alle müssen aufstehen?
Ich habe doch einen Stehschreibtisch, Tim. Ich ich mache meine Remotevorträge eh stehend.
Ich sehe, du hast deine Obsäcke am Start. Ja.
Ich habe meine am Start. Ich habe auch einen Screen hier, einen Greenscreen und so. Das kriegen wir hin.
Ja, wobei eine Jeans wäre vielleicht auch jetzt nicht so schlecht. Ach so. Corona-bedingt, kann ich jetzt leider nicht aufstehen, sondern zu allem, sorry.
Außerdem spielen die im Bundestag nicht die Nationale und da muss man auch nicht aufstehen.
Ach ja, na gut.
Ähm.
Wenn sie da nicht spielen, wo denn überhaupt sonst noch? Ach so, im Präsidenten.
Im Deutschlandfunk um Mitternacht oder so. Ähm ich muss
genau, ich muss eine Stellungnahme ab oder ich muss eine Sachverständigenanhörung zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei
das war ja jetzt seit über zwei Jahren in der Mache und im im Fleischwolf und ähm ja, das habe ich etwas blöd erwischt, weil
Der ursprüngliche Termin, der mir mal angekündigt war, war der fünfzehnte dritte.
Und ich habe dann so mir das für den fünfzehnten Dritten in den Kalender gesetzt und habe,
die Woche davor schön freigeschaufelt und die Woche davor auch ein bisschen leerer. Und habe mir jetzt so die letzten beiden Wochen sehr voll mit Arbeit
gepackt und dann kam so irgendwann die Einladung jetzt so, ja, alles klar, erster Dritter, Neumann, ne, Innenausschuss. Und ähm ja, die mir an mir war vorbei gegangen, dass sie den Termin nochmal verlegt hatten,
also entsprechend mein letztes Wochenende und mein nächstes Wochenende. Und meine Abende ein bisschen mit dem Lesen der,
hundertzwanzig Seiten füllt und dem Formulieren einer Stellungnahme dazu. Deswegen behandeln wir das auch einfach erstmal in der nächsten Sendung ausführlich. Es ist ein paar Jahre her. Ich war nämlich auch schon zu dem,
ersten IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwanzig fünfzehn äh Sachverständiger.
Da habe ich jetzt meine alte Stellungnahme noch mal rausgesucht und ein Video von der Anhörung gibt's auch. Und dann haben wir das erste Mal über das ähm,
geplante IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei null, habe ich eine Sendung mit Frank gemacht, die war am fünfzehnten April zwanzig neunzehn. Also man sieht dieses Themenfeld ist äh von einer ungeheuren Dynamik geprägt,
wie lange darüber jetzt schon diskutiert wird. Also wen es interessiert, kann sich äh gerne die, meine Stellungnahme zwanzig fünfzehn nochmal anschauen,
oder ein Video davon von der Sachverständigen Auskunft und die,
LNP zweihundertsechsundneunzig vom April zwanzigneunzehn behandelt, dass die ersten.
Fassungen des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes. Zwei Punkt null und ich glaube, das letzte Mal im Bundestag war ich zwanzig siebzehn.
Zur äh Ausweitung der Staatstrojans, also als Sachverständiger. Ich glaube, danach haben die mich da nicht mehr sehen wollen,
oder war da nur mal diese Anhörung zu Bots?
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, woran ich das oder woran ich das so ein bisschen festmache, ist, ich hatte noch nicht mit diesen AfD-Leuten zu tun.
Und ich bin mal gespannt wie das wird.
Es käme auch vorstellen, dass äh wahrscheinlich dann nochmal besonders unflätige Kultur, die dann äh Einzug gehalten hätte, oder?
Ja, das scheint ein bisschen interessant zu sein. Ich war verwundert, also ich habe die Liste der Sachverständigen natürlich bekommen und ich habe dann erstmal so ein bisschen versucht herauszufinden, wer denn von denen.
So weit herab gestiegen ist, dass er sich von der AfD hat nominieren lassen, weil die Sachverständigen werden ja von, also jede Partei kann da einen nominieren.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob die CDU nicht aus irgendwelchen Gründen sogar zwei da nominieren darf oder so. Aber äh,
dann wurde mir klar, äh da stand einmal NN drauf und es scheint so zu sein. Ich also Gerücht, was ich gehört habe, dass die AfD keine Sachverständigen mehr benennt,
weil,
die alle sagen, ja ich bin von der AfD benannt worden, ich will mit der Partei nichts zu tun haben und hier kommt meine Sachverständigenauskunft an den Deutschen Bundestag. Und diese Schmach wollten, die sich wohl nicht mehr geben
das erzählt man sich, erzählt man sich. Das ist ein Gerücht, was ich gehört habe. Ich habe keine Ahnung, so. Ich kann das nicht beurteilen. Ist wirklich ein Gerücht, was ich mir sehr gut vorstellen kann.
Okay und von wem bist du denn nominiert worden? Oder der CCC viel mehr, weil das ist ja jetzt im Rahmen vom CC nämlich an, ne?
Das ist äh ich gehe da als Vertreter des CCC hin und ich bin gebeten worden, von der grünen Partei,
von Bündnis neunzig, Die Grünen von Konstantin von Notz, der ja der in Experte der Grünen ist.
Auf dessen Bitte äh werde ich mich damit auseinandersetzen. Allerdings ist das, also es ist ja so klar, die Parteien benennen den, da gibt's aber jetzt nicht irgendwie,
Also da gibt es tatsächlich keine politische Färbung. Ne, die Parteien suchen sich natürlich jemanden aus, von dem sie hoffen, dass diese Person, was weiß ich, in ihrem Sinne argumentiert, aber es gibt da jetzt eigentlich,
keine nennenswerte Rücksprache oder so. Insofern also,
wäre es tatsächlich spannend oder eben eine Herausforderung, wenn man jetzt
weil man ja, man wird von der Partei nominiert, man wird aber vom Ausschuss geladen. Also nirgendwo steht dran, Linus Neumann von den Grünen, sondern einfach nur, ich bin da, weil die Grünen ihr Vorschlagsrecht
wahrgenommen haben und dabei die Wahl auf mich getroffen gefallen ist. So,
und das könnte eben wäre genauso, wenn jetzt die AfD das gemacht hätte. Und dann kann ich auch verstehen, dass man als,
ne, potentieller Sachverständiger Bürger in einem Bundestagsausschuss sich natürlich überlegt, na ja, äh sage ich jetzt, ich ich,
ich äußere mich nicht im Bundestagsausschuss zu einem Gesetzesvorhaben
weil die Partei, die mich benannt hat, mir nicht gefällt, obwohl ich mit der in keiner Form affiniert bin und auch nicht sein muss und die Einladung durch das Ausschusssekretariat erfolgt ist, ne. Also, ich kann schon verstehen, warum einige Menschen dann eben.
Einer solchen ähm,
Nominierung folgen und sich dann eben von der Partei distanzieren, aber insgesamt muss ich ja ohnehin sagen, dass ich da als Sachverständiger hingehe und eben Sachverstand anbringe und nicht ähm parteipolitik,
dass äh ist auch allen klar, insofern gibt's da auch keine Bemühungen,
von irgendjemanden mir zu sagen, was ich dir sagen soll, wobei sich natürlich die Parteien, die im Innenausschuss sitzen, ungefähr denken können, was äh ja ein Vertreter des CCC zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz sagen wird.
Und wie läuft das so technisch? Schreiben die eine Mail, rufen die an oder leuchten die mittlerweile so ein Pesthörnchen in die Wolken?
Also üblicherweise wo gefragt wird sag mal
wer über wir überlegen, dich dazu nominieren, hast du an dem Tag Zeit? Hast du da Bock drauf? Passt dir das gerade in den Kram? Und dann äh sagst du, jo und dann geben die halt die.
Also ganz langweilig, kein kein Superheldenshit oder so. Na ja, gut. Da arbeiten wir noch dran. Das ist auch Neuland.
Superheldenshit ist dann eher äh die die Kompensation, die da für Krees nämlich, ich glaube, so gut, also so.
Feuchter Händedruck sozusagen.
Ja, ich glaube, man kann ähm, müsst ihr nur mal gucken, ich habe ich habe mir diese Gebührenordnung da nicht angeschaut, aber ich glaube, du kannst irgendwie dreihundert Euro,
für die Stellungnahme und hundertfünfzig dafür, dass du da bist oder sowas. Aber auch nur, wenn die anerkennen, dass du ein Sachverständiger bist und nicht ein Interessenvertreter. Und die versuchen.
Also
das ist dann immer so, dass sie dann sagen, ja, aber der Chaos-Computer-Club ist ja eine Interessenvertretung. Und dann sagst du, nee Leute, ich bin als Sachverständiger zum Fachgesetz äh geladen worden. Äh was, worauf ich natürlich Wert lege, dass ich da nicht irgendwie einen Interessenverband vertrete, wie irgendwelche sagen wir mal,
Branchenverbände und äh ja, das ist also na ja, steht in keinem Verhältnis zum Aufwand und ist natürlich,
diese Interessenverbände, die werden ja von ihren die haben ja die kriegen ja ein Gehalt.
Ich meine, da müssten sie ja auch mal sagen können, äh äh welchen Interessen denn der CCC angeblich vertritt, äh da sollen sie auch mal eine Liste machen.
Also wenn die dann da mal äh ich gucke mal gerade ganz kurz, die haben mir Papierkram-Einladung, hier ist es. Datenschutzhinweise, Einladung, Entschädigung, so.
Entschädigung, Hotelrechnung, also Anreise, Anreise mit der BVG.
Ich versichere die Richtigkeit, aber es steht jetzt nicht bei, was das die Richtlinie, ah hier Richtlinie.
Anspruchsreisekosten kriegst du bezahlt, Reisekostenvergütung, eingeladen in Sachverständigen und Auskunftspersonen. Also,
Sachverständige sind eben die Unabhängigen Auskunftspersonen sind glaube ich eher genau mit Ausnahme von Interessenvertreterinnen werden auf Antrag die entstandenen Reisekosten ersetzt
Bei der Feststellung der Reisekostvergütung wird vom Grundsatz der Wirtschaftlichkeit und Sparsamkeit ausgegangen.
Daher können tatsächlich entscheidende Kosten nur in Sofa erstattet werden, als sie im Sinne dieser Richtlinie notwendig sind, Erstattung von Flügen, Bahnkosten, Taxi, Übernachtung, Land, Berlin, erhebt Übernachtungssteuer.
Ähm so und was steht da Entschädigung.
Schreibst du einfach hin, ein ein Mittagessen.
Ah hier, guck mal. Nee, Entschuldigung, ich habe das überschätzt. Pass auf. Also, die Entschädigung für Sachverständige und Auskunftspersonen,
Pauschal einhundert Euro,
für die Teilnahme an der Anhörung hat ein Sachverständiger oder eine Auskunftsperson auf Anforderungen eine schriftliche Stellungnahme abgegeben, erhöht sich die pauschale Entschädigung um einhundertfünfzig Euro. Also zweihundertfünfzig Euro, zack
auf den Tisch des Hauses.
Mit oder ohne BVG-Tickets?
BVG Ticket noch on top.
Ah, okay.
Aber natürlich nur nur das Hinrückticket, ne, weil Tagesticket.
Mittagessen.
Den Mittag, ne, von Essen steht hier nix.
Dass es ja sagen können, hättest ja ein Mittagessen mit den Frontex äh Freunden gehabt, vierundneunzigtausend Euro.
Genau.
Da kommt da wieder was rein.
Ja unter Corona-Bedingungen mussten wir halt, ne, der ganzen Saalmieten.
Es gab nur das ganze Hotel oder gar keins.
Genau, also zweihundertfünfzig Euro kann ich mir da abholen. Aber äh die Abrechnung dafür ist äh so anstrengend. Ich weiß es noch nicht genau, ob ich mir den Schatzscherz mache oder nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist es. Alles klar, da reden wir nächste Woche dann nochmal in Ruhe drüber.
Es gab jetzt, also es ist jetzt eh gerade Anhörungszeit. Frank äh Rieger, CCC schreibt auch gerade noch an der Stellungnahme zur äh,
TMG-Novelle, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ähm,
wo es darum geht, die ähm Abhörkapazitäten eben auch auf die Nummern befreiten, Tele Nichtnummern gebunden, einen Telemedien.
Dienste anzubinden, TKG-Novelle. So, die ist auch am ersten Dritten. Also da ist äh Frank und ich könnten uns da eventuell die die Klinke in die Hand geben.
Also es ist gerade Anhörungszeit. Ähm es sah auch eine Anhörung zum BND-Gesetz. Das hatten wir ja hier immer wieder behandelt. Ich erinnere dran, wir hatten Klaus Landefeld dazu bei uns in der,
Jubiläumssendung und der Auslöser des BNT-Gesetzes war ja die ganzen,
Rechts- und Grundrechtsverstöße des BND, die durch die Snowden Enthüllungen.
Und durch den NSA BND Untersuchungsausschuss zu Tage gekommen sind. Und die wurden ja dann durch eine BND Gesetznovelle,
nachträglich legalisiert. Und dagegen wurde dann wiederum geklagt und dann wurde es vom Bundesverfassungsgericht die BND-Novelle ähm für
nicht verfassungsgemäß erklärt. Und jetzt wollen sie das quasi wieder reparieren und,
Da soll jetzt zum Beispiel der BND ohne Wissen des jeweiligen Betreibers auf bestands-, verkehrs- und Inhaltsdaten zugreifen, ja? Mit anderen Worten,
sie erklären Telekommunikations- und Telemediendienstanbieter zu legitimen Zielen, staatlichen Hackings,
ja? Ähm ist natürlich äh da sind ja dann eben alle Bürgerinnen, die sich im Internet bewegen, betroffen und es gibt eben.
Die keine verfassungskonformen ähm keine verfassungskonforme Möglichkeit,
das äh umzusetzen,
weil nämlich dann jede und jeder künftig damit rechnen muss, dass persönliche Daten von staatlicher Seite mitgelesen und gegebenenfalls auch gespeichert und weiterverarbeitet werden, sagt,
sinngemäß Klaus Landefeld in dieser Anhörung. Das hat natürlich einen katastrophalen Vertrauensverlust, der,
Menschen in die staatlichen oder in die Kommunikationsinfrastruktur zufolge und animiert den Staat zum Zurückhalten von Schwachstellen nicht vergessen
gleichzeitig gehe ich eine Woche später dahin und soll den zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz äh Auskunft geben, wo sie über,
darüber reden. Sie wollen jetzt irgendwie Deutschland sicherer machen, ne? Also das ist,
etwas irrsinnig. Es gibt ja vor allem aber die Einschränkungen.
Bei diesem BND-Überwachung, dass ihr damit auch äh geheim Berufsgeheimnisträgerinnen und ähm,
Journalistinnen und Sonstiges targeten können und da sollen sie jetzt Filtersysteme nach Stand der Technik.
Benutzen. Und das Spannende ist, dass der Begriff Stand der Technik ist hier natürlich krass, weil nicht,
stand der Grundrechte, ne, sondern Stand der Technik. Und das heißt, wenn die Technik nicht in der Lage ist, deine Grundrechte zu wahren, dann ist das im Stand der Technik und nicht stand der Gesetze. Ähm also,
eigentlich sagen, so in diesem Bereich kann man dann eben sehr oft den Eco hören und auf den Klaus Landefeld natürlich insbesondere auch äh auf Reporter ohne Grenzen,
und äh,
natürlich alle so ungefähr, also das Ding wird wieder in in Karlsruhe landen, weil die erfolgreiche Verfassungsbeschwerde ähm war der Auslöser dafür, dass sie das Gesetz jetzt ändern müssen,
Und sie haben's nicht geändert, ja? Und da kann man sich eben auch sehr schön die Stellungnahmen von Reporter ohne Grenzen zu anschauen. Das ist wirklich.
Du fragst dich ernsthaft.
Nee, aber ist ja dann kein Problem. Dann müssen wir ja für unsere Aussagen hier auch nicht mehr gerade stehen, falls irgendjemand was zu bemängeln hat, sagen wir, na ja, wir haben zwar automatische Korrektursysteme, aber die sind jetzt einfach nur nach Stand der Technik. Wenn die nicht greifen, dann sorry, dann.
Rutscht uns halt auch mal was raus. Das hat dann halt einfach der Filter nicht äh aufgefangen. Ne.
Stand der Technik, ja? Das war übrigens auch,
bei dem ersten IT-Sicherheitsgesetz so ein Thema, dass sie da immer gesagt haben, stand der Technik, stand der Technik, wird also gesetzlich sind die die kritischen Infrastrukturen müssen Stand der Technik einsetzen und um den Stand der Technik zu definieren, haben sie dann gesagt.
Braucht es quasi branchenverbindliche Mindeststandards, ja? Und wenn die das, wenn die sich nicht an die Branchen,
spezifischen Mindeststandards halten, dann gibt's quasi Sanktionsmöglichkeiten, ja? Und die Branchen spezifischen,
Mindeststandards werden vom BSI definiert, ja,
und die Verbände der Branchen haben Vorschlagsrecht. Mit anderen Worten haben dann, ne, wenn jetzt so eine kritische Infrastruktur ist, was weiß ich, Energieversorgung.
Jetzt brauchte, brauchte das BSi einen Branchenspezifischen Mindeststandard,
Weil das BSI dir natürlich nicht selber schreiben kann, haben die Verbände, also die Energieversorgerverbände sich die branchenspezifischen Mindeststandards selber geschrieben und wenn die wissen, wenn wir die verletzten, ne,
kriegen wir Ärger mit Vater Staat, ne? Da weiß der ungefähr, wie gut die die schreiben, ne?
Das war eine reine Bürokratieübung, ja? Da haben die halt die IT-Sicherheit von gestern reingeschrieben, damit sie alle sagen konnten, ja hör mal, da sind wir aber hier weit drüber, ne? Also wir sind ja weit über Branchen Standard
sind wir hier, wie wir am Tisch sitzen, sind wir besser als als die Branche
und das ist damit haben die sich Jahre auseinandergesetzt, ne? Und es wurde natürlich niemand hat jemals irgendeine Sanktion bekommen,
oder hat jemals irgendeinen Mindeststandard nicht erfüllt, weil die sich den selber geschrieben haben? Und wer schreibt sich denn einen Branchen-Standard, äh den den sie nicht selber erfüllen
Ne, also äh Stand der Technik, wenn da irgendwo Stand der Technik steht, ähm das ist in den seltensten Fällen gut.
Lassen wir das.
Ja, ist ja auch völlig äh einfach eine reine Definitionsfrage und so offen lassen kann man sowas einfach nicht.
Du kannst natürlich also ähm wenn du jetzt.
Ich meine, bei bei Uploadfiltern oder so, also bei Technologien, die sich graduell weiterentwickeln, da kannst du natürlich schon irgendwie sagen, okay, hier geht es um Stand der Technik, ne? Aber das kannst du halt bei IT-Sicherheit nicht so gut machen,
und das kannst du bei Grundrechtsschutz nicht so gut machen, ne? Schwierig.
Naja, aber zum Glück wissen wir ja, dass die Branchen, die sind ja total im Bilde, was in diesem Land gerade passiert. Ähm.
Die haben einfach ausgebildetes Führungspersonal, die auf dem Stand äh der Technik sind.
Also Thilo Jung hat bei jung und naiv ein Interview gemacht mit Tim Höttges. Tim Höttges ist der CEO der Deutschen Telekom, also keine,
Kein irrelevanter Vorstand in Deutschland und ich,
war selber etwas erstaunt. Jetzt muss ich sagen, ich habe den Tim Höttges bei unterschiedlichen Konferenzen auch schon mal irgendwie kennengelernt. Und ich habe den eigentlich als ähm ziemlich aufgeweckt und ähm,
intelligent und interessiert kennengelernt und war dann wirklich bass erstaunt, dass er in diesem Interview,
Als er auf den Staatstrojaner angesprochen wird, folgendes sagt.
Scheint aber einer ein bisschen überrascht zu sein.
Und man merkt natürlich, okay, der hat jetzt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie den Begriff noch nie gehört hat, unter dem Namen Quellen TKÜ müsste er das natürlich schon irgendwann mal äh gehört haben
weil TKÜ ja nun wirklich ein Thema ist, was die Deutsche Telekom ja durchaus auch beschäftigt. Und auch, wenn sie so etwas bastelt, wie eine D Mail oder äh irgendwelche eigenen Messenger ähm
dann ist sie natürlich immer.
Den Telekommunikationsüberwachungsanfragen auch beschäftigt. Deswegen hat der Tilo ihm das ja dann auch erklärt und was mich dann wirklich so ein bisschen schockiert hat, ist, dass ihn darauf anspricht, dass ja mit eben dieser.
TKG-Novelle und den ganzen äh BND-Gesetzgebung und so, die Telekommunikationsanbieter.
Verpflichtet werden sollen, Hilfe zu leisten,
bei der Installation von Staatstrojanern. Also, dass jetzt quasi, ne, wenn jetzt irgendwie jemand sagt, okay, wir wollen die Nummer null eins sieben eins XY abhören und die benutzt aber,
So wir wir hören jetzt die Telefonate ab und die SMS. Das holt die sich dann zum Beispiel bei der Telekom und wenn sie jetzt sagen, oh, der benutzt aber außerdem noch Telegram, ja,
indem wir Attila Hildmann, der ist doch jetzt untergetaucht.
Ja
Attila Hildmann ist untergetaucht. So, die müssen den jetzt finden.
Der ist, den wollen sie irgendwie, warum sie den haben wollen, weiß ich nicht, ich könnte vermuten, dass sie den wegen Volksverhetzung haben wollen, aber was weiß ich schon. Ja, du,
dieses dieses äh diese Demokratie, ne? Es ist ähm gnadenlos in der Verfolgung von von arglosen Reichsbürgern, ne,
Das ist unglaublich, was die Schergen, ja.
Die Merkel-Diktatur. Ah ja.
Merkel-Diktatur, ja klar, die Merkel-Diktatur, die schnappt sich den jetzt. Der Typ macht doch immer voll einen auf hart, ne? Aber wenn wenn die Merkel-Diktatur mit ihrer Raute,
ihm greift, ne? Da versteckt,
der schreibt dir den der schreibt dir fünfhundert Telegramm-Nachrichten am Tag vom Widerstand, ne.
Aber jetzt verkriege ich das, ich war jetzt immer mit ihm über Volksverhetzung reden wollte. Also, ich weiß es nicht genau, ne? Sorry, ich weiß tatsächlich nicht, äh weshalb die nach dem Suchen, aber die würden gerne die äh die würden mal gerne mit ihm sprechen und der hat sich jetzt verpisst.
Oh, Attila, der Angriff der Merkelraute. Da können wir glatt einen Film draus machen.
Ich habe auch nur gelesen, dass der hat irgendwie zu einer Spontan-Demo aufgerufen gegen seine.
Was auch immer, ne? Bericht diesen schönen Dinge lesen. Äh es, es kamen gerade mal zehn Leute. Einer davon auf Sandalen.
Kommen da nicht mal mit ordentlich Springerstiefeln seine komischen Reichssoldaten.
Ja, das sind auch echt eine, ich möchte gerne Nazis.
Na, na, na, die meisten möchten gerne Nazis sind, gar nicht so schlechte. Die sind dann schon waschecht. Die haben halt nur nicht. Ja, wir kommen halt.
Nicht das richtige Schuhwerk sozusagen.
Auch ein Nazi kann äh auch äh auch Nazis tragen, Sandalen, ne. Aber okay, das wär's. So, jetzt jetzt sagen sie, okay, wir wir wollen eine äh Atis Telefon abhören, so,
Wir wollen die SMS, okay, kann die Tee kommen ausleiten. Wir wollen,
die Telefonate, okay, keine Telekom, ausleiten muss sie ja auch, so. Und jetzt zukünftig soll's dann so sein, so. Und jetzt, liebe Deutsche Telekom, hilf uns mal bitte dabei,
Staatstrojaner bei dem aufzuspielen, damit wir sein Telegram abhören können.
Und was das Schockierende an diesem Gespräch ist, das erklärt dir Thilo Jung, dem Tim auch. Und der ist ganz offensichtlich nicht,
Angelegenheit im Bilde und lässt sich dann am Ende zu der Aussage hinreißen.
Und als ich das gesehen habe, habe ich gedacht, das kann irgendwie nicht sein,
ist da los, ne? Also ich meine, ganz offensichtlich steht der auf dem Schlauch, ne? Und er hat er kriegt's nicht hin, da da zu merken und und irgendwie er findet nicht raus aus seinem Ding und hört vielleicht auch,
Thilo Jung, nicht zu, der ihm da gerade erklärt, indem ihr auch fragt, so, sag mal deine persönliche Meinung.
Und um diese persönliche Meinung windet er sich so rum. Auf jeden Fall habe ich mir gedacht, ey, das kann doch einfach nicht sein. Und da habe ich ein bisschen gegoogelt.
Und habe mir gedacht, dass der nimmst du gedacht, der Höttges hat nämlich eigentlich dafür ein, also der Vorstandsvorsitzende,
kümmert sich ja nicht umbedingt um solche Themen. Und er hatte nämlich die eigentlich bis März zwanzig zwanzig und das ist, glaube ich, das, was hier,
so ein bisschen das Problem ist, den Thomas Krämer als Vorstand für Datenschutzrecht und Compliance bei der Deutschen Telekom AG. Der ist also,
seid nicht ganz einem Jahr,
den alten Vorstand für dieses Resort los. Und das ist der einzige Weg, wie ich mir das erklären kann, weil wenn man einen Thomas Krämer nachts mit einem kalten,
Wasser weckt.
Und sagt staatstrojaner, quälen TKÜ und so, ne, dann gibt der dir die Antworten darauf. Der weiß selbstverständlich davon, was äh was was in diesem Bereich diskutiert wird. Ich weiß das deshalb, weil ich den eben auch bei unterschiedlichen,
ähm Anhörungen im deutschen Bundestag,
schon kennengelernt habe und weiß, dass der insbesondere im Bereich Datenschutz und IT-Sicherheit eben,
das ist etwas, was den interessiert, wo der im Bilde ist, so, ne? Und ich,
kann mir irgendwie nur, ich kann mir das jetzt echt irgendwie nur so erklären, jetzt geht der Krämer im März zwanzig zwanzig weg und der Tim Höttges hat wahrscheinlich seine neue Person, die er jetzt dafür hat, ich weiß nicht, wer die Nachfolgerin ist. Ähm,
wahrscheinlich einfach noch nie im Leben richtig gesehen, sondern hat die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Zoom-Konferenzen mit der oder so. Aber anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären. Also es ist ein,
unglaublich peinlicher Moment, ne, für für den CEO des deutschen Kommunikationsnetzes über so einen.
Über so ein Sachverhalt und über so einen Gesetzesvorhaben nicht im Bilde zu sein. Äh,
ja, aber ich kann mir's, ich kann's mir nicht anders erklären, als äh dass er da einfach, ja, nicht, nicht gebrieft war oder was auch immer, da jetzt das Problem war.
Ich kann's mir nicht erklären. Wie gesagt, das ist,
Bin mir relativ sicher, dass der Tim Höttges das schon sehr genau weiß und mir ist nicht ganz klar, wie's wie es zu diesem Interview gekommen ist. Ja, zu zu den Aussagen in diesem Interview. Die hat ja nun mal getätigt. Keine Ahnung, was da los war.
Knapp zwei Stunden unterhaltsames Interview von verlinken wir und dann habt ihr auch Spaß, wenn ihr euch das mal anhört.
Es ist manchmal ein bisschen gemein, also dieses dieses Format jung und naiv. Ja, ich ich glaube, das funktioniert äh relativ gut äh mit Leuten, die halt nicht wissen,
was da auf sie zukommt. Andererseits funktioniert es halt sehr gut mit Leuten, die wissen, was da auf sie zukommt. Also wenn man sich dann mal hier, wie hieß die.
Frauke Petry, die da ähm interviewt wurde, die schafft's natürlich dann auch so ein Format richtig gut zu füllen. Insofern,
Wer da nicht vorbereitet reingeht, äh darf sich nicht wundern.
Wer sich auch nicht wundern darf, sind Wirt. Wir dürfen uns auch nicht wundern. Ähm wusstest du also es ist so,
Also neben der vollständigen Verkackung dieser Corona-Pandemie, ja.
Haben wir auch noch anderes politisches Personal, äh wie zum Beispiel so ein Andi Scheuer, der die komplette,
Verkehrspolitik der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und dieses Mautsystem und was nicht alles,
verkackt, ne? Die kann die können ja nicht alles auf einmal verkacken, die brauchen ja Fachpersonal, um sicherzustellen, dass sie in den einzelnen Bereichen auch jeweils maximal verkacken, ne? Das ist ja nicht das Werk einer Einzelperson
So und.
Ab und zu mal was verkacken, sondern einfach durchgehend.
Durchgängig so vier Jahre lang zack, so jetzt ist das, jetzt ist das so. Andi Scheuer.
Ähm hat offenbar eine ähm Lebenspartnerin.
Namens Julia Reus. Und Julia Reus ist bis vor kurzem gewesen die Büroleiterin, der geht Digitalstaatsministerin Dorothee Bär im Bundeskanzleramt.
Vielleicht haben sie sich auf dem Flur kennengelernt, weiß ich nicht, ne. Vielleicht kennen die sich auch aus alten CSU Zeiten, Dorothee Bär ist ja äh auch äh aus der CSU, weiß man nicht.
Jetzt hat aber die äh Julia Reus sich entschieden, ihren Job zu wechseln und zwar äh möchte sie ab jetzt für Facebook arbeiten. Als Public Policy Director Central Europe.
Und sie wird dort ihr Job dort wird sein den Austausch,
zwischen Facebook und politischen Entscheidungsträgern sowie zivilgesellschaftlichen Akteuren weiter voranzutreiben. So,
Muss man sagen. Bomben Bombenställe, ne? Ich meine, du hast du bist äh liiert mit dem Verkehrsminister, deine ehemalige Chefin,
die ähm Digitalstaatsministerin im Bundeskanzleramt, wer würde die Qualifikation von Frau Preuß,
für diesen Job in Frage stellen. Ist doch völlig klar, dass Facebook äh dieser Person den Job äh gibt, ne? Also finde ich,
völlig in Ordnung. Also kann ich aus Facebooksperspektive total verstehen. Und solange äh unsere äh solange wir keine Gesetze,
juristischen Gesetze oder Gesetze des Anstands haben, die so etwas verhindern ähm läuft das doch easy durch.
Haben wir kein Gesetz für Anstand.
In der CSU nicht? Nee. Das mit dem Anstand haben wir nur äh ja, wo haben wir Gesetzes des Anstands? Keine Ahnung, bei anderen Parteien. Vor ein paar Jahren sind Politiker zurückgetreten, weil sie ein paar Bonusmeilen verflogen haben oder.
Die Dienstwagen genutzt haben und so, ja.
Für private Ausflüge. Das soll so die Skandalhöhe, die man eigentlich so früher so gewohnt war, die dann zum Rücktritt geführt hat. Aber so Geld verballern und irgendwie Kontakte äh durchreichen. Das scheint irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig äh relevant zu sein.
Dorothee Bär könnte das nicht machen, für die gäbe es da so einen direkten Wechsel. Der wäre ihr verwehrt. Die müsste dann nochmal ein Jahr äh bezahlten Urlaub nehmen oder so, bevor sie so eine Position einnehmen kann, ne.
Es ist.
Also um's vielleicht gleich nochmal klarzumachen, die Tatsache, dass sie jetzt die Freundin von Andi Scheuer, es gibt jetzt im Ganzen nur so ein kleines Sahnehäubchen oben drauf.
Das ist nicht das eigentliche Problem. Das eigentliche Problem ist
dass wir ohnehin schon relativ wenig Digitalkompetenz haben, aber wenn dann sozusagen das bürokratische Einfallstor äh einfach mal die Seite wechselt, ja und äh an der Stelle ja auch eine ganze Menge strategisches äh Wissen,
nimmt, darüber wie sieht der Staat das, was es sozusagen in der Diskussion, wie stellen wir uns gegenüber großen Digitalkonzernen auf? Und dann äh wechselt halt einfach mal dieses Wissen,
quasi brühwarm. Ja, also wenn wenn ein Jahr später, man kann jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob ein Jahr später irgendwie ausreichend ist. Ja, das
kann man diskutieren. Aber so eine Policy-Diskussion ist nach einem Jahr nicht mehr dieselbe.
Vor allem Tim, wenn du mit der gleichen Person, wenn du die noch im Telefon hast,
als die Büroleiterin der Digitalstaatsministerin, ja? Wo du drangehst und sagst, alles klar. So, das sind jetzt noch zwei Hobs zu Angela Merkel.
Und die meldet sich als nächstes bei dir und sagt, jo äh jetzt sind's nur noch zwei Hops zu Mark Zuckerberg, ne. Da sind ein bisschen andere Interessen im Spiel, so und das ist also das geht halt so nicht. Sorry,
Und ähm ja offen also offenbar geht's ja so und an an Facebook Stelle hätte ich natürlich auch diese Person eingestellt, aber ähm.
Weißt du, dass das Leid.
Erodiert doch in diesem Land seit so vielen Jahren, dass Vertrauen in die verfluchten Institutionen, ja? Und die arbeiten auch wirklich mit aller Mühe daran, so. Und das sind solche äh Personalien, die halt einfach.
Ja nicht das Feingefühl dafür aufbringen oder ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass niemand, der,
mal gesagt hat, hm, vielleicht gar nicht so gut, wenn du äh als Büroleiterin der Digitalstaatsministerin zu Facebook wechselst. So, aber vielleicht war's auch einfach so, dass das aufkam und die sich gedacht haben, naja okay, allen klar, da gibt's halt irgendwie einmal schlechte Presse,
Augen zu und durch, die der erste, das erste Monatsgehalt kompensiert den äh kompensiert den Stress schon gut, oder? Also.
Tja, also es ist ähm beklagenswert, sagen wir's mal so. Es ist einfach äh nicht okay und es zeigt einfach, dass hier mindestens so das Feingefühl fehlt. Das ist ja schon mal schlimm genug.
Aber das ganz grobe Feingefühl Tim. Also da muss.
Das ganz grobe.
Das ganz grobe Feingefühl so.
Oh Mann, ey.
Ja, das grobe Feingefühl äh das schien auch äh Australien ein wenig äh zu fehlen.
Ja, das ist eine spannende Geschichte gewesen.
Es ist immer noch eine spannende Geschichte.
Na, die ist ja jetzt halbwegs vorbei, ne.
Findest du? Na gut, schauen wir mal.
Also was passiert? Australien plant das Media Bargening Law und.
News Media Bargening Code.
Und die Idee dieses Gesetzes ist ähnlich.
Der Idee des Leistungsschutzrechts in Deutschland oder in Europa.
Dass man versuchen möchte, Newsagregatoren irgendwie Geld dafür abzunehmen, dass sie die Inhalte von den.
Medienseiten multiplizieren. Und.
Ich muss so ganz vorsichtig, es gibt ein ein Anlass sich darüber Gedanken zu machen, weil ja,
In zunehmendem Maße so soziale Netzwerke und auch bestimmte Google News Dinge. Einen eigentlich von der tatsächlichen Webseite der Anbieterin fernhalten.
Also, dass du so, ne, keine Ahnung.
Und so.
Genau, dann hier Facebook News, veröffentliche deinen Inhalt doch direkt bei uns und hier nochmal eingebettet. Ach, willst du wirklich auf die Seite oder reicht dir schon hier diese Zusammenfassung, ne? Also es ist schon.
Es gibt da einige Praktiken,
vermutlich nicht ganz in Ordnung sind, die aber, muss ich auch direkt sagen, ich glaube auch vom aktuellen Urheberrecht her so schon quasi bekämpfbar wären. Ähm und dieses Newsmedia Bargelding.
Sagst du heißt es sogar Lott.
News Media Bargeld Code. Ja, also wenn sie.
Dessen Ziel war eben zu sagen, okay, wir möchten von Google, für Google News Kohle haben und wir möchten von Facebook,
auch ähm Kohle haben, wenn,
internationale Nachrichteninhalte dort dargestellt werden. Und zwar für diejenigen, die diese Nachrichteninhalte produziert haben.
Bereitgestellt werden oder verlinkt werden.
Genau, jetzt kommt jetzt kommt der spannende Teil, weil,
Es kann natürlich auch einfach nur verlinkt werden. Und bei dem Verlinken kommt natürlich jetzt der Punkt,
Ich glaube, das war damals Mario Sixtus, der ist vor vielen Jahren schon so gesagt hat, ne? Das ist so, als würdest du als Restaurant,
von dem Taxifahrer Geld verlangen, weil er eine Besucherin zu dir gefahren hat, ne? Das kannst du.
Nicht machen. Die Besucherin ist zu dir gekommen und du kannst jetzt nicht noch diejenigen, die sie, die ihr dabei geholfen haben,
Strafen, ne? Und ähm das ist also dieses Leistungsschutzrecht, was ja dann eben,
im Prinzip zum Ziel hat, dass das, was du brauchst, um einen Link zu machen, nämlich dass du da den Titel wenigstens hinschreibst, der dann kommt, wenn man da drauf,
dass man das irgendwie kaputt macht, ne? Dass man und das ist ja im Prinzip die Idee des Leistungsschutzrechtes, das so eng zu fassen, dass natürlich kannst du dahin lenken, aber wenn du irgendwie
Teile des Inhalts nimmst, um diesen Link zu markieren, dann hast du damit schon unser Urheberrecht äh.
Ja äh oder hast du etwas getan, wofür wir Kompensation haben möchten? Das ist ja die Idee des Leistungsschutzrechts. Am Ende aber nichts anderes als eine Link,
Steuerung und Link, eine Linkteuermachung. Und jetzt fand ich das sehr spannend, Facebook hat dann gesagt, alles klar.
Und da war dieses Gesetz noch nicht verabschiedet, ja. Ähm.
Ist immer noch nicht verabschiedet.
Genau, es ist immer noch nicht verabschiedet, aber als Facebook diesen Schritt gemacht hat, war es auch nicht verabschiedet. Sagen.
Dieses Gesetz selber kam in in Australien wie auch in Deutschland,
natürlich was ein Wunschgesetz der großen Medienhäuser,
in Australien, ne? Das bei denen heißt der, der Springer Verlag sind dann eben die Medienhäuser von Rupert Murdock, ne, die also mehr oder weniger eben in diese Richtung lobbyiert haben. Also, hier auf beiden Seiten,
keine traditionellen Sympathieträger. So und jetzt passiert also folgendes.
Australien hat das dieses Gesetz auf Entwurfsstadium.
Und sagt, äh wir möchten das tun und Facebook schon in in Antizipation dieses Gesetzes, das noch gar nicht verabschiedet ist, schalten die im Prinzip ähm.
Dieses Verlinken ab. Also sie sagen australische Verlage können jetzt nicht mehr irgendwelchen.
Inhalt auf ihren Facebook Pages posten.
Sie können zwar noch die Sachen aus der Vergangenheit sehen, aber nicht mehr äh neue Inhalte auf ihre Facebook Pages äh pushen. Internationale.
Können das zwar weiter machen, aber diese internationale Publisher, deren Links und Posts werden australischen,
Audience ist nicht angezeigt. Also das wird wenn jetzt irgendwie was weiß ich so, die BBC oder so was, ne, kann dann halt auf auf Facebook posten, aber das wird nicht mehr der australischen Audience angezeigt,
die kompletten australische Bevölkerung oder Facebookbevölkerung kann nicht,
internationalen oder australischen News Content auf Facebook anschauen oder posten.
Und die Internationale Community kann australischen News-Content nicht mehr sehen,
und auch nicht mehr teilen. Also die haben den kompletten Sack zugemacht für die kompletten australischen News Provider und für die australische Nutzerinnen haben sie halt die kompletten News Haaren zugedreht, ja?
Und was ich, ich finde es interessant, wie sie das ähm.
Verargumentieren. Und zwar sagen sie, sinngemäß.
Das Gesetz versteht fundamental nicht, wie das Verhältnis ist zwischen Facebook,
und diesen Publishern, die ihren News Content dort verbreiten. Und sie grenzen sich ab von Google.
Äh wo sie sagen, bei bei der Google Suche ähm stellen die Publisher ja nicht.
Freiwillig und gezielt ihren Content ein,
Bei Facebook posten sie aber spezifisch ihre eigenen News auf Facebook, weil sie dadurch mehr Abonnements verteilen und ihre ähm Audience vergrößern und auch damit.
Kostenlos tun sie das vor allem.
Genau.
Und du hättest gesagt, wir bieten euch den kostenlosen Service an. Ihr könnt hier posten, wobei ich mir sicher bin, dass die das meinst du nicht, dass sie denen auch Geld abnehmen für für die Facebook-Pages oder haben sie den.
Naja, für Werbung und für Reichweitenvergrößerung und sowas, dafür nehmen sie ja Geld, das ist ja dann quasi auch ihre Dienstleistung, aber es ist ja grundsätzlich so, dass ein Facebook-Account erstmal kostenlos ist.
So
Und äh dafür äh werden sie dann sozusagen auch noch zur zur Kasse gebeten. Also man kann ja wirklich jetzt von Facebook halten, was man will, aber äh die Nummer, also,
die geht gar nicht und meine,
Australien ist halt einfach so ein bisschen auch so der der Urknall alles äh medialen Elends, ne, dadurch, dass Robert Mörderch da äh seine Zentrale hat und der hat natürlich da einen Einfluss auf die Gesetzgebung in USA, das Ganze
Projekt ist ja auch noch von diesem
glaube ich, gestartet worden, der mittlerweile nicht mehr Ministerpräsident ist, aber der unter den vielen großen, australischen Ausfällen, die die da äh hatten, nochmal ein besonderer,
Ausfall war. Ja äh ja. Auf jeden Fall Facebook hat sich gewehrt.
Und das hat auf jeden Fall eine Schockwelle äh durchs Land geschickt.
Facebook sagt, sie versuchen hier uns zu bestrafen für Content, nachdem wir nicht gefragt haben. So.
Ja, genau.
Äh das ist also ja, ich äh muss sagen, dass es ich spontan hier eigentlich Facebooks Argumentation ganz gut folgen konnte.
Facebook sagt dann auch noch im letzten Jahr haben wir ungefähr fünf Komma eins Milliarden kostenlose,
Refereals, also Links, also jemand geht von uns dorthin äh an australische Verlage vergeben, die ungefähr vierhundertundsieben Millionen australische Dollar wert sein sollten. Ähm,
Für uns selber ist der Gewinn aus diesem Business minimal, weil News weniger als vier Prozent des Content ausmacht.
Den Menschen in ihrem äh ja Facebook Newsfeed sehen und sagen halt so, ja okay, auf die vier Prozent können wir auch verzichten, wenn ihr die vierhundert Millionen äh äh australischen Dollar nicht haben wollt.
So, krasserweise ist es aber so.
Diese Aktion mit der australischen Bevölkerung nicht besonders gut gesessen hat. Und es hat wohl ähm.
Tatsächlich wurde es eher wahrgenommen, als ein Erpressungsversuch Facebooks.
Gegen die Regierung mit einem, ja, Gesetzesvorhaben. So wird es mir zumindest von meinen,
australischen Kontakten berichtet.
Ja, so hatte ich das auch. Ich habe auch äh so Mails bekommen von Leuten aus Australien. Das ist auch erstmal überhaupt nicht verstanden haben
Da war das so eine IDalreaktion. Ich meine, das geht ja auch schnell, ne. So, oh Facebook äh hängt jetzt hier die australischen Nachrichten,
böse, böse, böse. So und da war die Mail schon geschrieben an mich, wo ich nur meinte, so ja ähm
Link Text und so, also seid ihr jetzt auf einmal irgendwie Freunde eurer, eurer Regierung oder was? Und dann schrieb er mir auch gleich zurück, so, ah ja, okay, stimmt, jetzt habe ich's mir mal genau angeschaut, hast eigentlich recht.
Also sie haben wohl auch den Fehler gemacht, äh eine Reihe Nicht-News-Seiten mitzublocken, wie äh Krankenhäuser, Gesundheitsdienste, äh Buschfeuer melden, also das, wo man sagen kann, hier brennt's, ja?
OK also halt
Dinge, die keine News fahren und das hat natürlich bei den Leuten nicht so den, den besten Eindruck ähm hinterlassen. Und.
Warum sie spezifisch sich auch nochmal auf Google beziehen ist, Google hat sich halt mit denen geeinigt und hat gesagt, alles klar, wir klären das äh,
wir gießen ein bisschen Geld bei euch aus und läuft, ne? Also man hatte quasi, wenn Facebook sich gewehrt hat, auf mit der Begründung, die sich ja gerade auch so ein bisschen wiedergegeben habe, hat Google halt gesagt, ja, cool, alles klar, kein Thema. Wir zahlen.
Und ähm ja, es ist wirklich äh schief gegangen mit dem Ergebnis, dass Facebook jetzt vorgestern.
Bekannt gegeben hat, dass sie nach Diskussionen mit äh dem zuständigen Ministerien und Trasura.
Ähm ein eine Lösung gefunden haben.
Und es wird jetzt irgendwie ein ähm es wird jetzt Änderung an dem geplanten Gesetz geben und als Ergebnis dieser Änderungen,
Können sie jetzt weiterhin äh ihrem Interesse folgen der Öffentlichkeit diese News zugänglich zu machen? Und.
Wie sie sich geeinigt haben, sagen sie aber nicht so wirklich. Also sie sagen nur ähm.
Also sagen, ja, es wird jetzt, wir werden halt konkrete, gezielte Deals machen dürfen, können, die ähm ja, auch berücksichtigen, dass die Publisher ja auch etwas,
von wir dehnen ja auch einen mehrwert stiften.
Das klingt wieder wie diese Lizenzierungsnummer aus dem Leistungsschutz äh äh Gesetz, so nach dem Motto, am Ende zahlen die nämlich gar nichts, ne? Man muss auch noch dazu sagen, dass halt die australische Regierung äh Facebook dann auch gleich erpresst hat, indem sie ihre ganzen
Werbung, die sie so auf Facebook geschaltet haben, zurückgezogen haben. Also das ist das das läuft nicht sauber
So, das ist jetzt irgendwie, da da gibt's jetzt irgendwie keine guten und keine bösen, sondern da versuchen die sich irgendwie äh am Ende glaube ich auf Kosten der der kleineren,
ne? So nach dem Motto Facebook ist zwar eigentlich das Ziel, aber dann stellen sie fest, so hm, naja, okay, wenn die jetzt nicht mehr so richtig mitspielen, dann klappt's auch nicht, aber so ganz drauf verzichten können wir ja jetzt auch nicht.
Dann zahlen halt die anderen und äh wir machen da irgendwelche speziellen Deals und Lizensierungen, die da wahrscheinlich Google und Facebook am Ende irgendwie nicht äh im Wesentlichen nichts,
und äh dann haben aber alle irgendwie ihr Gesetz bekommen und dann ist das irgendwie durch und Robert Mörder,
äh Ruhe. Ich meine, ich habe das so nur so ein bisschen aus dem Augenwinkel verfolgt, aber es war schon erstaunlich, wie auch äh zum Beispiel in UK darüber berichtet wurde und das ist ja auch komplett mörderich entfestet diese ganze Medienlandschaft.
Und äh da spannen dann so viele Leute irgendwie sofort vor die Kameras, die also da auf Facebook eingeprügelt haben
das ist schon irgendwie nicht sauber. Also man sieht auch schon so, dass also wenn wir wirklich so ein so ein mediale.
Also es gibt so eine Medienkrankheit, so eine Medienpandemie irgendwie auf diesem Planeten so und äh die Wurzel, die sitzt schon in Australien,
das kann man schon irgendwie mal so festhalten.
Also das ist, ich finde, also es ist ein,
Ich glaube auch, dass bei Facebook jetzt die Leute sitzen und sich denken so what, Alter, wir hatten das Ding doch eigentlich in der Tasche. Wie haben wir es denn geschafft, das zu verkacken? Äh ich ich also in Spanien war's ja dann zum Beispiel so, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, ne. Die haben irgendwelche.
Ja, genau.
Leistungsschutzrechte gemacht, dann hat Google halt gesagt, na okay, dann machen wir Google News aus, wenn ihr das nicht haben wollt. Und dann hast du lange Gesichter, ne, weil Google News ja schon für viele Leute ganz ganz hilfreich ist.
Aber na ja.
Äh also ich meine du hast es konnten ja auch auf beiden Seiten echt nicht die Guten gewinnen, ne.
Keine guten da.
Okay, kommen wir äh zu der nächsten völlig überraschenden,
Nachricht haben sich mal ein paar Leute hingesetzt und haben gesagt, okay, wir gucken uns mal eine an,
Also eine AI, die anhand Videos äh Menschen analysieren soll und dann zum Beispiel ihre,
Charaktereigenschaften prognostizieren soll, ne? Jetzt habe ich hier auch schon öfter mal erzählt, ich glaube das ist halt äh in der Persönlichkeitspsychologie so die,
Basisannahme ist, dass es fünf Charaktereigenschaften gibt.
Die fundamental sind, also fünf Eigenschaften, aus denen sich viele andere erklären lassen. Das ist,
Offenheit für neue Erfahrung, das ist so ein bisschen, sage ich mal, der kulturelle Interesse Faktor, der auch,
relativ stark äh mit Intelligenz korreliert. Es gibt die Gewissenhaftigkeit, ne, also,
wie gewissenhaft man Dinge erledigt, wie äh wie pünktlich man ist und Vereinbarungen einhalten und ne sauber und sortieren und putzen und aufräumen und so, ne? Dann gibt's die Extraversion,
Das ist also im Prinzip der,
darf, den eine Person hat an Interaktion mit anderen Menschen, ja? Also Introvertierte Person ist, glaube ich, der bekanntere Begriff, ne, also bezeichnet Menschen, die auch gerne mal für sich alleine sind,
Extraversion eben bedeutet, dass du ja aufblühst im Kontakt mit anderen Menschen.
Da gibt's die Verträglichkeit, also so eine grundsätzliche Stimmung, ne, wenn irgendwas nicht passt, sagst du dann, okay, passt schon oder suchst du den Konflikt, setzt deine Interessen durch, ne? Und am Ende dann mit der fünften,
Basiseigenschaft,
Skala Neurotizismus, ja, denken jetzt viele immer zuerst an irgendwelche Freudgeschichten der Neurose, aber eigentlich lässt sich Neuroutizismus am besten übersetzen, nämlich sagen wir mal, Ängstlichkeit
ne? Also und das sind immer Skalen, auf denen jeder Mensch hat quasi einen,
imaginären Wert auf einer Skala zwischen,
wie auch immer du die normierst. Also kannst offen sein für neue Erfahrungen oder nicht, kannst gewissenhaft sein oder nicht, kannst introvertiert sein oder extrovertiert,
verträglich oder nicht und wenn du,
hoch wenn du stark auf der neuterroten Gala bist, dann bist du relativ von Angst und Sorge geprägt, während Leute mit niedrigem Neurotizismus eben,
wenig wenig Angst vor Dingen haben, ja? Auch wenig Sorgen und so weiter.
Und jetzt haben die da so eine AI geprüft, die diese ähm von so einem Start-up bereitgestellt wird, das quasi anhand eines Videos,
eben erkennen möchte und diese Person bewerten möchte. Und da haben sie mal ganz einfache Sachen gemacht, haben sie ein Video von einer Person genommen, haben die einfach vorm Greenscreen aufgezeichnet und haben mir Hintergrunddinge geändert, ja? Gleiche Person,
und nur ein anderer Hintergrund und wenn du dann hier so ein Bild in den Hintergrund gehängt und dann wird die natürlich irgendwie höher auf dem
Offenheit für neue Erfahrungen gewertet, vor allem ja offenbar hier kulturell interessiert und so, ne. Wird auch gewissenhafter, wahrscheinlich weil das Bild gerade hängt. Und es ist wirklich,
ja total äh lächerlich, wie sie dann auch hier mit einer äh Frau, die hat ähm.
Diese einmal sehr gut ausgeleuchtet haben
und einmal etwas weniger gut. Und sie selber hat eine dunkle Hautfarbe. So. Und da wird dann natürlich auch komplett andere Charaktereigenschaften raus, weil äh einfach nur, wie sie beleuchtet ist
Und das Spannende ist jetzt sagen sie natürlich, okay, hier jetzt hast du eine so eine beknackte AID, die solche Entscheidungen für dich trifft und die,
ja, geliefert dir komplett abiture Ergebnisse, weil du hast ja in beiden äh Bereichen die gleiche Person da sitzen. Ich würde jetzt nur leider, leider, leider,
ein sehr gemein zynischen Kommentar sagen und sagen, das sind im Zweifel die gleichen Fehler, die Menschen genauso hätten. Und.
Das zeigt einfach nur, dass die.
Dass die AI halt ja auch nicht besser als ein Mensch ist, aber das Problem ist, dass wir das ja glauben, ne? Weil,
wenn wenn ich dir sage, guck dir mal dieses diese Person an und schätze die mal ein und dann sagst du ja, okay, ich schätze die so und so ein und dann sage ich auf einmal her, aber unsere unsere AI sagt, die ist äh,
ist eigentlich hoch neurotisch. Und dann denkst du dir natürlich, oh, oh, der Computer sagt, das ist eine hochneurotische Person, lass mal kurz schauen,
neurotische Personen wollen wir nicht haben. Wir brauchen jemanden, der den, äh der den Klärschlamm im im ähm im Kernkraftwerk irgendwie wegfegt, äh dann lass uns die Person mal lieber nicht nehmen, ne?
Wir machen Tausende solcher Dinger mit irgendwelchen AIs, ohne das zu wissen, dass sie,
eben derartige Esterepe nur,
wieder manifestieren, die gleichen Fehler machen wie wir und wir denken aber, der Computer wäre irgendwie klüger als ich. Und das ähm zeigt diese diese Studie sehr schön.
Ja, ich glaube, wir hatten das auch mit Thomas äh Lunninger schon mal in Österreich gab's doch da mit dem Arbeitsamt äh glaube ich eine ähnliche äh Geschichte, dass da so ein Algorithmus äh
sozusagen die Berufe, die Berufsbewerber zuordnen sollte
und auch diese Systeme basieren halt einfach immer nur so auf den bisher etablierten äh Wissen, ne, so dass dann einfach,
zu kurz kommen. Also alles, was Minderheit ist und benachteiligt ist in dem Prozess. Das ist dann quasi in so einer AI, in so einem in so einem Lernmodell, das hat sozusagen einfach nur die alte Welt gelernt. Und genau die wendet sie dann auch an
und nichts anderes kommt dann auch am Ende dabei raus. Das heißt, du lernst einfach quasi das Ignorieren von,
ja Randgruppen auf der einen Seite beziehungsweise du du trägst eigentlich die manifestierten Probleme weiter vor Ort. Und,
deswegen das ist auch etwas, glaube ich, was diese Gesellschaft lernen muss, dass eine AI,
Das klingt ganz fancy, ne? So ah ja, Intelligenz und so, voll gut. Hat man viel zu wenig von? Sondern es ist ein eigentlich was anderes. Es ist einfach ein,
System und.
Lernsysteme funktionieren super um irgendwie Schrauben auf einem Fließband zu erkennen, weil da weiß er irgendwann mal, wie eine Schraube aussieht und wenn die Schrauben sich so ein bisschen ändern, dann kriegt sie das irgendwie schon hin
Aussagen über eine Zukunft, die auch sagen wir mal Werte und Policies äh in sich tragen sollen
sind einfach mit dem mit dem Alten so nicht abzudecken und deswegen ist es sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig, da auf diese Algorithmen zu setzen.
Ja, das ist und die Frage, weißt du, was das das Spannende ist? Das ist ja ein Start-up, was das als Produkt anbietet.
Und letztendlich ist das, sage ich mal, allenfalls eine,
Das, was hier damit gemacht wurde, ne, so eine, so eine Basisvalidierung, die haben die offenbar nicht gemacht. Das heißt, das Produkt, was die sich,
anschicken, irgendjemanden anzudienen oder wo sie von irgendwelchen Investoren Kohle für haben, um um,
um letztendlich ein paar Experimente mit irgendeiner AI zu machen, von der sie selber nicht wissen, was sie drauf hat, ja? Ähm.
Das wird dann hier mit einem relativ einfachen Setting sofort auf die Probe gestellt und das sind und und und entblößt, ja? Und das ist offenbar die Qualitätssicherung, die die selber nicht vornehmen. Ich glaube, wir haben auch über diesen Fall gesprochen, wenn ich mich nicht
täusche. Ich glaube, das war bei Gitthup. Ich glaube, es war bei Gitter oder war es bei Amazon.
Amazons äh ja ja Amazon hat das, glaube ich, die die hat das mal die hatten das mal äh probiert, um neue Leute zu finden und haben's dann aber wieder eingestellt.
Nee, nee, die haben Folgendes gemacht. Die haben gesagt, alles klar. Wir kriegen ja alle Bewerbungen digital rein. Ne? Und,
wir können jetzt einfach mal 'ne AI lernen lassen.
Erkennen, welche wir am Ende angenommen haben. Ja? Und dann soll die bitte nur zu den ähm.
Zu den Vorstellungsgesprächen, die Leute mit der höchsten Wahrscheinlichkeit einladen, dass wir sie annehmen,
So, was ist das Problem in dem Versuchsaufbau? Das Problem in den Versuchsaufbau ist, dass zwischen dem, dass du die Leute nimmst.
Und dass sie alle eine Bewerbung bei dir ein äh äh tüten, liegt ja schon der Mensch, der potenziell von Vorurteilen geprägt, die Entscheidung trifft, wer überhaupt zum Vorstellungsgespräch eingeladen wird und wer nicht.
So und
was die jetzt gemacht haben, die haben von AI lernen lassen und haben dann gesagt, alles klar, stellt sich raus, die AI ist wirklich besser, weil die Leute, die sie uns vorschickt, wir haben mehr Vorstellungsgespräche mit Abschluss. Das heißt, die hat tatsächlich gut die Person.
Gebildet,
Auswahl zu den Vorstellungsgesprächen macht, nur noch ein bisschen besser, nämlich sie hat dann auch noch die Person mit abgebildet, die bei den Vorstellungsgesprächen dann am Ende die Auswahl treffen, wen sie einstellen oder nicht. So,
Was hat sich rausgestellt? Das Ding hat eisenhart gegen ähm Frauen und Minderheiten ähm diskriminiert und,
Es war, wie es bei einer AI üblich ist, nicht erkennbar, dass oder warum sie das tut. Du kannst natürlich dann nur irgendwie ähm.
Je nachdem wie groß der Datensatz ist, kann das Ding vielleicht zum Beispiel nach, ja, was weiß ich, Art der Schule ähm aussuchen, ne. Ich glaube, Namen und Hautfarbe haben sie bewusst nicht reingefüttert.
Aber es hat quasi die unterliegenden Faktoren der Benachteiligung
Ja, also in Deutschland wäre das jetzt zum Beispiel sowas, was relativ einfach ist, äh in meiner Generation wäre halt noch gewesen, ein Mann
oder männliche Person erkennst du daran, dass die ein Jahr später bei gleichem Geburtsjahr in die Universität eintritt. Ja, weil die zwischendurch noch ähm
Zivildienst oder ähm oder Bundeswehr oder so Quatsch machen musste, ne. Ähm und du hast natürlich relativ viele.
Nicht direkte Faktoren, die aber nun mal stark mit so etwas wie ethnischem Hintergrund und den damit einhergehenden Benachteiligungen korreliert sind, sodass diese AI halt am Ende,
ganz klar gegen äh Frauen und Minderheiten diskriminiert hat. Und letztendlich hatten die ihren vorherigen jetzt einfach nur in den Computer gegossen.
Manifestierung der Vorurteile.
Ja. Und dann, so kriegst du deine äh so kriegst du deine Gesellschaft auch nicht geändert, ne? Wenn du sagst, alles klar, wenn du sagst, ja die Vorurteile sind halt so, die die bestätigen wir jetzt einfach, wir wir wiederholen die einfach die ganze Zeit, brauchst dich nicht zu wundern.
Wir könnten so schöne Sachen machen mit den Computern, ne.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber soll nicht sein.
Nö, stattdessen ähm äh das ist ja auch so eine Sache, die ich nicht ganz verstanden habe. Äh dass also in Deutschland gibt's das zum Glück noch nicht so in noch nicht so viel. Kennst du die?
Na ja, da sieht man eine Menge von. Im Netz.
Eine Türklingel mit eingebauter Kamera, die äh die dir von Amazon bereitgestellt wird.
Und irgendwie noch so eine App hat.
So 'ne Anbindung, ne? Wenn dann siehst du halt irgendwie, ach was weiß ich, wer war denn vor der Tür, ne? Man findet dann viel so Paketdiebstahl scheint irgendwie ein Thema zu sein in den USA, weil die Post das Paket vor die Tür liegt,
und dann zockt das einer und dann haben die Leute halt ihr Video von,
ihr Video mit der oder was weiß ich, hat irgendeine Schlange auf dem äh hat sich in der Tür versteckt und schnappt dann nach den Leuten und dann siehst du ganz viele Videos, hat sich die Polizei gedacht, ey ist doch total praktisch.
Wenn wir jetzt hier so Demos haben mit den Black Lives Matter Protesten und so und die ziehen durch irgendeine Nachbarschaft und da sind überall die, können wir ja mal fragen, ob wir die privaten,
Überwachungskameras,
nicht irgendwie dazu bringen, mit uns zusammen zu arbeiten. Und offenbar arbeiten inzwischen zweitausend US-Polizeibehörden mit Ring zusammen.
Die Polizei kann jetzt nicht direkt selber auf die Überwachungsvideos zugreifen, äh sondern sie braucht wohl die Zustimmung der jeweiligen Nutzerin.
Aber ähm die Mitarbeiterin kontaktieren dann die Hausbesitzer und sagen ja, weißt du noch, irgendwie zu dem und den Zeitraum, als hier die Leute über die Straße gegangen sind, die bei dir gefilmt wird.
Würdest du das nicht mal hier im Rahmen einer Strafverfolgung äh der Polizei zur Verfügung stellen? Geil, oder?
Ja, das ist ähm das Problem, ne? In dem Moment, wo die Daten dann erstmal da sind, dann werden sie halt auch irgendwann passend missbraucht werden.
Alte Geschichte. Wir wiederholen wir uns ja am laufenden Meter und das ist äh halt so ein wunderbares Beispiel. Selbst wenn die Leute überhaupt keine böse Intention haben,
einfach nur sicherstellen wollen, dass sie äh sehen können, wer vor der Tür steht oder wo das Paket abgegeben wurde oder wer es geklaut hat.
Ja, dann ist halt einfach dieses Material einfach da und dann schafft es Begehrlichkeiten.
Und ich muss auch sagen, das ist auch wirklich grade bei den Videoüberwachungssystemen finde ich's halt sehr ärgerlich, dass ähm.
Dass wir dass dass da die Technologie, das Feld diesen Cloud-Anbietern überlassen hat.
Dass dass nicht jemand hingegangen ist, gesagt hat, okay, wir machen mal jetzt wirklich eine Privacy Schafe äh,
Kamera. Ja, weil natürlich, es ist ein Thema, dass Leute eine Kamera an der Haustür haben wollen oder ihren Garten überwachen wollen und so. Und es wäre halt tausendmal besser, wenn man denen ein Angebot gemacht hätte,
wo sie halt, was weiß ich, verschlüsselte Videos von mir aus auch in irgendeine Cloud packen, aber nicht so, dass dass irgendwie dein freundlicher Ring Mitarbeiter
bei dir anruft und sagt, die Polizei interessiert sich für das Video von deiner Kamera. Und die meisten Leute, die sich Kameras irgendwo hinhängen, denken wahrscheinlich so, oh, die Polizei interessiert sich, wenn das Video vor meiner Kamera, endlich kann die mal irgendein Arschloch auf dieser Welt überhaupt gebrauchen. Ähm,
und stellen das natürlich dann auch noch gerne zur Verfügung.
Ciao.
Aber da hätten wir, da hätte man bessere Technologie. Da hätte das Feld hätte man denen nicht überlassen sollen, bleibe ich dabei.
Jetzt den Polizei oder den Ring.
Amazon.
Ach so, ja.
Irgendwelche Cloud-Cloud-Kamera an der Haustür. Also ich.
Bescheuert. Das sind wirklich so Sachen. Äh ja.
Aber weil es am Ende die einzige Kamera ist, die, sage ich mal, konkurrenzfähig äh ähm einfach ist, äh ist natürlich auch klar, dass sie dann relativ schnell,
offenbar Marktführer werden mit dem Zeug.
Na ja kommen wir zur vorletzten Kurzmeldung in den USA gab es ein Angriff auf die Trinkwasserversorgung der US Kleinstadt Old Smart
ja? Und da äh wurde also festgestellt, dass sich da irgendwie jemand äh da reingehackt hat
Und er hätte dann irgendeinen, was war das denn, irgendeine Chemikalie? Ähm hinzugefügt worden.
Ähm also der hat, genau, der hat die Grundwasseraufbereitungsanlage,
da hatte mehr Natriumhydroxid hinzugefügt und zwar normalerweise werden da hundert und der hat das aber auf elftausendeinhundert gestellt.
Und das hätte äh gefährliche Reizungen verursachen können, wenn das jetzt dauerhaft so geblieben wäre,
ja? Offenbar wird diese Einstellung mit einem Mauszeiger vorgenommen, den ein Mitarbeiter,
beim Bewegen gesehen haben will. Ja, glaube ich jetzt auch, ja. Ähm,
und dann haben sie die Sache untersucht, na, sie, die Mitarbeiter, wie von Geister hat, jemand hat die Maus bewegt, ne? Ja, wie kann das denn wohl sein? Ja,
waren Windows sieben Rechner, mit dem die da ihre komische Natriumhydroxid,
in der Grundwasser, in der Grundwasseraufbereitung regeln. Und damit die nicht immer zur Arbeit fahren müssen, hatten sie da halt einen Teamvieher drauf mit
Standardpark, also mit einem Passwort ohne irgendwie Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung oder lokale Bestätigung des Zugriffs. Ja und das war's.
Hackerangriff.
Angriff, ja?
Das ist dann auch, weißt du, da äußern sich natürlich dann auch irgendwelche qualifizierten viel zu früh für und und äh dazu und und äußern sich irgendwie über die Unsicherheit der der kritischen Infrastrukturen. Ganz ohne Frage, ist es natürlich auch, ja? Es ist,
eine katastrophale Absicherung einer äh kritischen Infrastruktur. Du fragst dich sowieso, warum ist da überhaupt ein Rädchen, wo man auf elftausendeinhundert drehen kann?
Wenn äh das Reizungen verursachen kann. Also wieso können die das überhaupt einstellen, wenn da wenn das, ne, das ist ja das,
Meine Güte, das ist das einhundertelffache des Wertes, den sie da offenbar standardmäßig fahren. Und ja.
Mittlerweile ein offizielles Security äh Advisory, Cyber Security Advisory, wo sie dann auch drauf hinweisen ist.
Wäre jetzt mal nicht so eine geile Idee. Mit so Desktop Sharing Software zu arbeiten und überhaupt könnten sie mal ihr Windows sieben vielleicht auch mal updaten, weil das kriegt keiner Updates mehr und,
wer jetzt vielleicht für so ein Wasseraufbereitungssystem nicht die richtige Anwendung. Experten ey.
Alles Totale Vollprofis, das äh krass, oder? Also ich meine, ich verstehe's nicht. Manchmal verstehe ich's wirklich nicht.
Es sagt auch äh dann, jetzt stellt sich noch dazu raus, dass es vermutlich ähm die Tat eines,
ähm ja frustrierten ehemaligen Mitarbeiter zwar, das ist so ein sehr typischer typisches also jemand, der da äh vielleicht irgendwann keinen Bock mehr hatte, in der Kläranlage zu arbeiten.
Ein verwirrter Einzeltäter.
Nee, nee, daher kannte der wahrscheinlich einfach das äh Passwort. Also so äh stellt es sich eben der Chef der US Cyber Sicherheitsagentur Chris Crabs vor.
Dass es eben auf einen,
und unzufriedene Mitarbeiter zurückgeht. Übrigens auch der Grund, warum du, ne, also es geht ja so weiter. Die der arbeitet ja nicht eine Person, die da irgendwie die Natriumhydro,
sieht, Zufuhr steuert mit dem Mauszeiger, sondern fünf und die haben natürlich alle das gleiche Passwort, ne? Und wenn einer gefeuert wird, dann ändern die natürlich nicht das Passwort. Ja, ja.
Ja und dazu kommt ein Employee ist ja vielleicht unter Umständen nicht nur dann
wenn er da schon nicht mehr arbeitet, sondern der hieß das ja auch voll häufig vor allem innerhalb von Firmen, die da grade noch arbeiten. Und wenn so ein System auch keinerlei
Vorkehrungen bietet, dass man so einen Wert überhaupt so falsch einstellen kann, ohne irgendwie eine sekundäre Warnung rauszuhauen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie es da war. In dem Artikel heißt es, es hätte noch andere Sicherungssysteme gegeben, die letzten Endes verhindert haben oder hätten, dass da dass dass diese Mischung auch tatsächlich äh.
Im Wasser bei den Leuten an den Zapfhändlern ankommt, das
kann ich nicht jetzt beurteilen. Grundsätzlich sollte man aber sozusagen drüber nachdenken, dass eine Fehlbedienung immer möglich ist, egal ob sie jetzt intentional war oder nicht.
So und damit sind wir jetzt wirklich bei,
einer kleinen zu diesem Gamestop-Ding. Es ist jetzt so, dass die äh der einer der Auslöser.
Ähm der als wesentliche Kraft hinter dieser Gamestop Aktienaktion äh gilt, nämlich,
äh wird nun verklagt von einem,
Investor der Verluste gemacht hat das ist davon war zu auszugehen dass die sich danach irgendwie.
Noch äh klagen würden. Das ist zwar skill, der äh,
Unter dem Pseudonym Roring Roring Kitty hat er eben sehr lange sich zu diesem Gamestop geäußert und jetzt wird,
davon ausgegangen, dass er ein lizensierter Finanzprofi,
wäre. Und er hätte sich aber als Amateur ausgegeben. Und das könnte natürlich potenziell eventuell für ihn tatsächlich problematisch werden. Gleichzeitig verklagen sie aber auch Robin Hood,
Also die klagen sich da jetzt alle in Grund und Boden. Äh ist ja klar, wenn da irgendwie viel Verlust gemacht wird und irgendwie ähm.
Hier und irgendwie Probleme kriegen, die haben immer noch genug Kohle für Anwälte. Also das wird jetzt ähm,
eine äh wird jetzt halten,
noch ein ein neojuristische After-Mart haben. Mal gucken. Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass sich da jetzt nur nochmal die äh ähm US-Anwältin noch ihren Fernanteil abholen aus der ganzen Nummer.
Die Taschen vollmachen. Ja.
Okay und die USA haben mal wieder äh Hacker angeklagt und.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr interessant. Also ich kann das jetzt auch nur so wiedergeben. Drei Hacker, der Lazarus-Gruppe. Und die haben ähm den Wirt.
Unterstellt, dass sie eine ganze Reihe Hacking-Angriffe für äh Nordkorea durchgeführt haben sollen. Ähm.
Und es ist, was ich daran interessant finde, ist eigentlich, dass die USA halt in der Lage sind, die persönlich zu identifizieren mit Foto, ja? Und ähm.
Also die wurden jetzt nicht in USA.
Nein, die die äh leben in Nordkorea, ne? Und äh sie sollen beteiligt gewesen sein an dem Angriff, also der,
äh ja, einer der schädlichsten Schadsoftwares überhaupt, ne, dem.
Viper, der ja mit dem E-Turnal Blue Explode von der NSA, das von den Shadow Brokers geleakt wurde, um zwang äh so Mitte zwanzig siebzehn muss das gewesen sein, eben eine Reihe,
Windows-Rechner platt gemacht hat. Unter anderem waren da glaube ich diese elf Krankenhäuser in Großbritannien betroffen und so weiter.
In Deutschland waren's die Anzeigetafeln der Deutschen Bahn. Ähm also das, daran sollen sie beteiligt gewesen sein, aber was viel,
krasser eigentlich noch ist, äh was Lazarus zugeschrieben wird, ist, dass sie Swift gehackt haben. Einige Jahre zuvor. Und sich da ähm also das Swift-System ist quasi das Überweisungssystem zwischen,
den Banken und da haben sie äh hundert Millionen Dollar äh gestohlen. Das ist ein super krasser ähm,
Super krasser Hack, sehr kompliziert, äh muss man sich mal in Ruhe äh durchlesen, könnte man eigentlich hier mal behandeln? Oder ich weiß nicht, es gibt ja so Podcasts, würde schätzen, Darknet, Diaries oder so, haben das sicherlich mal behandelt.
Wo sie sehr äh.
Mit sehr klugen Vorgehen tatsächlich es geschafft haben, hundert Millionen US-Dollar halt von einer Bank zu exfiltrieren und schnell genug woanders hin zu überweisen. Ähm spannende Geschichte und.
Einem von den Dreien, denen haben sie auch schon diesen Sony Hack zur Last gelegt. Das war ja auch, also es war zwanzig vierzehn, bärenstarke Sache. Da wurde ja Sony Pictures Entertainment
wirklich völlig kaputt gemacht, ne? Die haben ja alle Daten da rausgeholt, die den ganzen Laden einmal äh öffentlich gelegt und die
vermutete Motivation dafür war, dass die eine Komödie über ähm Kim-Jung-Il machen wollten.
Du erinnerst dich, wir haben da auch im Logbuch drüber gesprochen, aber es war sehr, es ist schon etwas länger her, ja, zwanzig vierzehn.
Das äh ich glaube zu dem Zeitpunkt, als wir diesen Hack besprochen haben, haben wir, sind wir, war noch nicht die Hypothese oder der Verdacht, dass das irgendwie echt eine Racheaktion war für eine Komödie, über den.
Über den Giftzwerg da. Aber also es gibt auch verschiedene Gründe, warum.
Also in Nordkorea wird ja einfach vom größten, großen Rest der Welt äh auf allen möglichen Ebenen boykottiert und ähm.
Dadurch haben die natürlich Probleme, also ihre Währung ist quasi nix wert. Ne, also die können eh nirgendwo einkaufen und bei denen, wo sie einkaufen können,
müssen sie halt unglaublich viel bezahlen, weil keiner Lust hat äh auf auf die nordkoreanische Währung. Ich weiß leider noch nicht mal genau, wie die heißt.
Weil ich bisher auch noch nie irgendwie in der Gelegenheit war, äh diese Währung zu nutzen. Das heißt, die haben natürlich großen Bedarf an,
Devisen, insbesondere US-Dollar und das treibt dieses Land,
quasi in die äh Kriminalität, ne? Und äh darin sind sie offenbar ziemlich gut. Also,
muss man den lassen, aber andererseits offenbar nicht gut genug, weil sie ja jetzt offenbar eine in der Lage waren, Einzelpersonen zu identifizieren. Und da frage ich mich echt, wie sie das gemacht haben.
Mit Teamerica natürlich.
Team America.
Team America ist da eingerückt in Nordkorea und hat das alles.
Würde eher schätzen, die haben irgendwie am am Eingang.
Der ist sozusagen der die nordkoreanische Währung, teilt man ein in einhundert John.
Ganz einfach.
Und was der Wechselkurs ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie.
Ein Euro sind tausendeinhundertzwölf One. Also so hundert, hundert ungefähr neun Cent.
Und was kostet denn, was kostet ein Mittagessen in Bonn?
Vierundneunzigtausend Dollar. Das ist der Standardpreis international. Das ist einfach Festpreis.
Ach so, Frontex-Mittagessen.
Ja, es ist einfach vollkommen normal, verstehst du? Das ist einfach nichts, nichts Besonderes.
Normal Alter.
Gebe ich auch jeden mit da raus.
In dem Köpfchen. Okay, dann sind wir jetzt ähm.
Wir haben uns heute bemüht, etwas aufzuholen.
Weil wir ein paar Themen mal aufholen mussten und ich auch ein bisschen freischaufeln wollte, weil ich davon ausgehe, dass wir nächste Woche,
ein bisschen über das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz vielleicht noch reden. Gleichzeitig in den,
in Österreich wurde jetzt schon die die Impfnachweisdebatte losgetreten, ne?
Also hier der der Kindeskanzler äh der möchte jetzt irgendwie ähm irgendwelche grünen Kärtchen haben und mit mit digital und so, um Leuten wieder das Reisen und Einreisen zu erlauben.
Ja, die Diskussion werden wir auch kriegen.
In mir kommt das irgendwie so vor, als hätten wir die die haben wir doch alle schon letztes Jahr geführt. Also tatsächlich, ich glaube, äh habe ich da nicht mit ähm mit Lea auch drüber gesprochen in Lokbuchfreiheit. Ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher.
Das weiß ich nicht. Das kann sein, dass du darüber gesprochen hast. Wir haben da nicht drüber gesprochen, aber diese ganze Impfgeschichte äh wird jetzt auf jeden Fall nochmal auf äh Fahrt aufnehmen.
Zwanzigster Mai zwanzig zwanzig, Logbuchfreiheit Episode fünf. Haben wir uns da haben wir das Thema schon abschließend erörtert. So.
Schließend. Und Ergebnis?
Ist ja ein Jahr her. Aber kann man sich nochmal angucken.
Ich sage, ohne ohne Impfung kommt keiner auf Malle.
Äh ich will erstmal eine Impfung haben. Und wenn die, wenn wenn die Leute alle ihr Astra nicht wollen, sollen die mir das geben.
Ja oder mir? Ja.
Okay, das soll das Thema. Also im Notizausweis wird ein Thema werden,
Was ich aber noch abschließend loswerden möchte an dieser Stelle, ist unsere Freundinnen von frag den Staat, suchen eine Leiterin für die Presse- und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit,
Die Leiterin der Presse- und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit koordiniert.
Kommunikation von frag den Staat nach außen und entwickelt sie strategisch weiter. Um die Arbeit des Projekts einer größeren und diverseren Öffentlichkeit zugänglich zu machen. Die Bewerbungsfrist,
ist der achte März zwanzig einundzwanzig. Ähm,
Ihr könnt euch das da anschauen, da wird noch sehr genau gesagt, wer was sie suchen und so weiter. Und ähm.
Mit wem ihr dort zusammenarbeitet, wisst ihr sicherlich als Hörerin von Logbuch Netzpolitik sehr gut.
Arne Sensrott werdet ihr dort äh nach Corona irgendwann mal über den Weg laufen können und äh.
Ja, Sie möchten dir die Möglichkeit geben, mit viel Gestaltungsspielraum eigene Ideen umzusetzen.
Und ja, achtundzwanzig Urlaubstage im Jahr. Zu besetzt ist die Stelle zum ersten Mai. Ich glaube, ähm dass,
ähm ist eine interessante Stelle, selbst wenn man äh im Anschluss nah äh an diese Tätigkeit zu Facebook als Policy Europe Global Lead Pipapo wechseln möchte, weil von da aus kann man das wenigstens machen.
Und hat irgendwie eine Qualifikation aufgebaut, die das Recht.
Ja, da hat man die Kontakte, hat mal einen Einblick in die Policis. Das ist einfach, das ist ein Sprungbrett. Ja, ist also wenn ihr schon immer mal zu Facebook wollt, fangt erstmal mit fragt den Start an. Vielleicht auch.
Vorbei. Ja, so, jetzt sind wir durch.
Ja Schluss. Schluss mit Lokbuch für diese Woche.
Ja. Vielleicht sollten wir an dieser Stelle noch sagen, wir haben eine Reihe an Empfehlungen bekommen, wie man ähm.
Wie wir Klapphaus ersetzen können. Leider äh würde bisher kein.
Systemangeboten, das, ich sage mal, überzeugend sich mit mehreren hundert Personen nutzen lassen würde. Ähm sehr viel wurde uns Mambel empfohlen und ich habe einfach leider die Sorge, also
Ich kenne das aus mit sagen wir mal zwanzig, dreißig Leuten, dass sie die erste viertel Stunde damit beschäftigt bist, Leuten,
einfach grundsätzliche.
Themen des Anstands zu erklären, nämlich dass man sich, dass man nutzt, dass man nicht mit einem Speaker äh also nicht Lautsprecher und einfach in die in die Kiste schreien nutzt und
dass es ein Echo gibt, wenn man automatische Voice Activation hat und so und,
Selbst mit geübten Leuten sehe ich, dass in größeren Gruppen nicht funktionieren. Erst recht nicht mit
irgendwie weit über dreihundert. Ähm das da bin ich leider nicht überzeugt, dass das funktionieren würde. Dann gibt es einige sehr vielversprechende webbasierte Verfahren,
die aber sagen, dass sie so ab fünfzehn Teilnehmerinnen.
Ähm irgendwie zu Problemen führen, was dann leider auch nicht,
diesen diesen unseren Bedarf entsprechen würde. Ich freue mich aber weiter äh über Empfehlungen und ich muss sagen, das Killerfeature habe ich jetzt identifiziert, ist eben diese Trennung.
In die Audience, dass also der größere Teil der Leute zunächst nicht sprechen kann, dadurch nicht stört,
Ja, also nicht durch Nebengeräusche stört, reinatmen, die ganzen äh Schnaufen und Hinter und nebenbei spülen und was man nicht alles hat, ne, das kommt einfach alles nicht. Und dann eben sich melden und auf die in die Audience geholt werden. Das scheint mir das Feature zu sein,
was so Massenkommunikation hier einerseits ermöglicht und andererseits so.
Doch nah und und intuitiv und partizipativ gestaltet.
Ja, also es.
Weiter über Empfehlung, ich weiß Tim Klapphaus ist das Beste und niemand wird jemals da dran kommen, aber ich würde mir.
Habe ich nicht gesagt.
Wenn wir da eine, wenn wir da ein, ein, ein brauchbares System äh empfohlen bekommen, äh wechsel wieder sofort hin.
Ja, vielleicht noch als Ergänzung, also
Das ist das eine, äh was es allerdings auch bei Klapphausen, deren Development sozusagen überhaupt erst ähm interessant gemacht hat, ist eigentlich diese Einführung der Moderationsrollen und diese
Regeln und Rollen und Funktionalitäten, die sind so ein bisschen das Salz in der Suppe. Einerseits.
Andererseits kriegt natürlich so ein System zwangsläufig, ne, auch äh seinen Nutzen durch äh den Aspekt des äh des Social Networks, was dahinter steht, ne? Das ist halt auch ein Ort, wo sich mittlerweile eine ganze Menge Leute tummeln.
Ja aber Tim, das ist ja für unseren Anwendungszweck nicht relevant.
Ja, aber das ist äh auch gerade ja,
aber egal. Das können wir offen lassen. Auf jeden Fall The Race ist Orden. Es gibt mittlerweile eine ganze Menge Clowns, also diese
dieses Konzept äh wird jetzt nicht in einer App verbleiben. Es gibt mit Dive, mit Stereo und so weiter, Twitter, Spaces. Alle versuchen jetzt grade dieses Ding irgendwie auch zu knacken und das wird noch recht sportlich werden in der nächsten Zeit.
Trotz also wir können zu dieser Sendung so etwas gerne machen, allerdings nicht mehr in dieser Woche und da dann wär's schon Montag und dann machen wir auch die nächste.
Ja, nee, das müssen wir jetzt nochmal ausfallen lassen. Steht äh für dich eine Menge an, für mich auch noch ein bisschen und da passt es jetzt gerade mal nicht rein, aber wir greifen das auf jeden Fall wieder auf.
Wir wir können das wie gesagt gerne im Anschluss an die nächste Sendung machen, zum Beispiel, wir können einen Termin machen, was ist denn mit dem äh was.
Bist du dir jetzt schon sicher, dass du den nächsten Termin halten kannst?
Wenn er äh nach dem ersten äh März liegt, ja, dann ist halt die Frage, sei es Mittwoch oder Donnerstag sein? Was ist da dein, was passt dir?
Was mir nächste Woche beides grad nicht so recht. Da müssen wir uns schon nochmal drüber unterhalten. Wir kündigen das in der nächsten Sendung an. Ich kann's jetzt.
Alles klar. Dann kündigen wir die nächsten Sendungen an.
Alles klar. Dann war's das von uns. Leute, bis bald. Tschüss. Macht's gut.
Ciao, ciao.